I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application. It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an environment. goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way, because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside, as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's
我是Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家儿童与青少年心理健康服务（CAM）机构担任助理心理咨询师。我购买并阅读了玛丽安（Marianne）的《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书，作为我申请临床心理学培训期间的陪伴。事实证明，它确实是很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它让我有机会沉浸在人们的故事中。它及时提醒我，不要过于纠结于环境目标，而要珍惜并享受我们一路走来所完成的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作对于我们身边的人以及我们自己来说都很重要，且意义重大。它还让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对我这样的人来说很重要，因为我
had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though. because once you've started reading, it's tough to put it down. What if one of the most powerful mental health tools isn't an app, isn't a self-help book, and isn't even therapy? What if it's a ball of wool and a pair of needles? In this episode, clinical psychologists Dr. Mia Hobbs and Dr. Paula Redmond, join me to discuss why knitting and crochet might be doing far more for our mental health
走过一段曲折的旅程，并非进入该行业的典型路线。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业原因。不过，要做好暂时搁置晚间任务的准备，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。如果最强大的心理健康工具不是应用程序，不是自助书籍，甚至不是心理治疗，那会怎样？如果它是一团毛线和两根针呢？在这一集中，临床心理学家米娅·霍布斯（Dr. Mia Hobbs）博士和保拉·雷德蒙德（Dr. Paula Redmond）博士加入我的节目，讨论为什么编织和钩针编织对我们心理健康的作用可能比大多数人意识到的要大得多。嗨，欢迎来到《心理学，其实》（Psychology, Actually）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天还有两位临床心理学家同行和我一起。我们有保拉·雷德蒙德博士和米娅·霍布斯博士。欢迎你们，伙计们。谢谢你们邀请我们。谢谢你们来到这里。
than most people realize. Hi, welcome along to psychology, actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I'm joined here today by two fellow clinical psychologists as well. We've got Dr. Paula Redmond and Dr. Mia Hobbs. Welcome along, guys. Thank you for having us. Thank you for being here.
（注：原文索引2与3内容重叠，此处按原文顺序翻译）
So today we are thinking about the well-being, or should we say, will-being benefits of crafting hobbies like knitting and crochet. Could you tell us a little bit, perhaps Paula, about why you think this is a really great thing for people to be doing? Yeah, thanks, Marian. Well, this is our favourite subject,
所以今天我们正在思考像编织和钩针编织这样的手工爱好对幸福感，或者我们应该说是“意志感”（will-being）的好处。保拉，也许你能告诉我们一点，为什么你认为这对人们来说是一件非常棒的事情？是的，谢谢玛丽安。嗯，这是我们最喜欢的话题，
so we could talk about it all day. I think that, I guess, Mia and I know from our personal experience as knitters and crafters about how we've benefited from having a, creative practice that's, you know, something that has been really consistent in our lives. And I guess I'm really passionate about sharing some of those benefits more broadly. So I guess, you know, what lots of knitters in particular and crochet as we kind of think about those two things together, talk about is how knitting can really support a kind of soothing process.
所以我们可以整天谈论它。我想，米娅和我从我们作为编织者和手工爱好者的个人经验中知道，拥有一种创造性的实践对我们有多大益处，你知道，这是我们生活中非常一致的事情。我想我真的很热衷于更广泛地分享其中一些好处。所以我想，你知道，许多编织者，特别是钩针编织者，当我们把这两件事放在一起考虑时，谈论的是编织如何真正支持一种舒缓的过程。
So that kind of rhythmic, repetitive movements can be really relaxing and really help us kind of physiologically wind down, activate that soothing system, help kind of calm the body, are a form of really accessing mindfulness. And for many of us, you know, who might find that difficult just to kind of sit still and be mindful, having something that helps us access it is really beneficial and really useful. also can help kind of calm the mind as well. And what is also really great about knitting is not only does it kind of do that soothing bit, but it can also kind of activate that drive system in terms of giving us a sense of accomplishment, the kind of joy and pleasure of dealing with the sensory materials, you know, the colours and the yarn, tapping into creativity, personal expression, identity, values, making something meaningful, showing care through gift giving.
那种有节奏的、重复的动作可以非常放松，真正帮助我们在生理上放松下来，激活那个舒缓系统，帮助平静身体，这是一种真正进入正念的形式。对于我们许多人来说，可能觉得仅仅静坐和保持正念很困难，拥有一种能帮助我们进入这种状态的东西是非常有益和有用的。它还可以帮助平静心灵。编织的另一个伟大之处在于，它不仅能起到舒缓作用，还能通过给我们一种成就感来激活我们的驱动系统，那种处理感官材料（你知道，颜色和纱线）的快乐和愉悦，挖掘创造力、个人表达、身份认同、价值观，制作有意义的东西，通过赠送礼物表达关怀。
And also being able to offer us a way of connecting with other people, whether that's in knitting spaces, knitting communities, in person online, through, you know, creating things for other people it has this wide range of benefits and because knitting and crochet are so diverse in terms of what you can make the kind of projects it's kind of infinite possibility you never kind of get to the end of that there's always something to learn something to do new ways of expressing yourself and because it is so portable you can carry it in your bag, you know, you can take it anywhere. It's a really practical, accessible way of accessing all of these different benefits that you can tap into, you know, intention. If you need
它还能为我们提供一种与他人联系的方式，无论是在编织空间、编织社区，还是在线下或线上，通过为他人制作东西，它具有广泛的好处。而且因为编织和钩针编织在制作项目方面非常多样化，可能性是无限的，你永远不会走到尽头，总有东西要学，有新的方式来表达自己。而且因为它非常便携，你可以把它放在包里，随身携带。这是一种非常实用、易于获取的方式，可以让你利用所有这些不同的好处，你知道，带着意图。如果你需要
something that's going to really help calm you down, you can maybe choose an easy project that you don't really have to think. You can just get into the rhythm of it and, you know, it might even help you concentrate in a meeting or stay present or wait. you know, for something tricky. But if you're wanting something that might really take your mind off, you know, distressing thoughts, for example, you know, cut through rumination, choosing a project that is more complex, that really requires you to think and focus, can be really helpful.
一些真正能帮助你冷静下来的东西，你也许可以选择一个不需要动脑的简单项目。你可以进入它的节奏，你知道，它甚至可能帮助你在会议中集中注意力，保持当下，或者等待。你知道，处理棘手的事情。但如果你想要一些真正能让你转移注意力，摆脱痛苦想法的东西，例如，切断反刍思维，选择一个更复杂、真正需要你思考和专注的项目，会非常有帮助。
So it's both kind of practically accessible, but also psychologically accessible because you can tap into it in a way that fits with what your psychological needs are. I love that. I do wish I was better at crafty things, is what I would say. And I love how portable it is. Mia, I think I even reached out to you last year to say that I was on holiday and I'd seen a lady poolside in a bikini knitting and dancing at the same time. And I was like, wow, it's just really, really nice to see. And I love, before we were chatting, we were talking. about the idea of an analogue bag and actually how that can be really, really good for us in a time when we're switched on. Could you tell us your experiences of your analogue activities? Well, yeah, so I think it's something Paula and I've both been asked by journalists a lot recently in the press,
所以它既是实际可行的，也是心理上可行的，因为你可以以符合你心理需求的方式利用它。我喜欢这一点。我确实希望我更擅长手工活，我是这么说的。而且我喜欢它如此便携。米娅，我想去年我甚至联系过你，说我在度假时看到一位穿着比基尼的女士在泳池边一边编织一边跳舞。我当时想，哇，看到这一幕真是太好了。我喜欢，在我们聊天之前，我们谈到了模拟（analogue）包的概念，以及在我们需要时刻保持在线的时代，这实际上对我们有多好。你能告诉我们你对模拟活动的体验吗？嗯，是的，所以我认为这是保拉和我最近在媒体上被记者问到很多次的问题，
that there's this idea of younger people, I would get the generations muddled up, but younger people who are kind of digitally native turning to analog hobbies. And this concept of an analogue bag had kind of gone a bit viral on social media, which is the idea of having a bag where you put in some analog hobbies, which could be knitting, some other craft, crosswords, a book. Probably in the same way many of us have packed a bag for our children, you know, when we go out for lunch and don't want them to be on a screen and we know they can't sit still.
有一种观点认为年轻人——我会把代际搞混，但那些数字原住民的年轻人——正在转向模拟爱好。而“模拟包”这个概念在社交媒体上有点走红，也就是准备一个包，里面放一些模拟爱好项目，比如编织、其他手工、填字游戏、一本书。可能就像我们许多人为孩子准备包一样，你知道，当我们出去吃午饭，不想让他们看屏幕，而且我们知道他们坐不住的时候。
Certainly I used to do that when they were small. And the idea of, and I kind of realized I'd been carrying one for the last 20 years since I've, you know, have been carrying my knitting around with me. But I think part of what one of the things journalists have asked us about is why are younger people so interested in what has traditionally been thought of as an older person's hobby. But I think there's something about, you know, as Paula was saying, about this kind of sense of achievement that if you're doing things, I mean, a lot of us in our jobs are doing
当然，当他们小的时候我经常这样做。而关于……我意识到过去20年来我一直随身带着一个包，因为我一直带着我的编织品。但我认为记者问我们的其中一件事是，为什么年轻人对传统上被认为是老年人的爱好如此感兴趣。但我认为，正如保拉所说，这与那种成就感有关，如果你在做事情的话。我的意思是，我们很多人在工作中做的事情
things we can't see. We don't, you know, so few of us have a physical product at the end of our working day. And I don't know about the two of you, but I certainly remember qualifying as a psychologist. I'm finding that hard because I think in the process of being a trainee, I was always striving to meet the next goal and someone would tell me I'd pass that essay or that case report or I knew what the next goal was. And actually becoming a psychologist had been a goal for a super a long time. And, you know, when you're probably quite driven as a person, and then you get out the other end, and you're like doing the nine to five, and your goal is helping people feel better, which is really like, you know, it's not very objective. It takes quite a long time. It
是我们看不见的。你知道，我们工作一天后很少有人能得到一个实物产品。我不知道你们俩怎么想，但我确实记得作为一名心理学家获得资格的过程。我觉得这很难，因为我认为在成为实习生的过程中，我总是努力去实现下一个目标，有人会告诉我通过了那篇论文或那个案例报告，或者我知道下一个目标是什么。实际上，成为一名心理学家是一个很长期的目标。而且，你知道，当你是一个很有动力的人时，当你走出那个阶段，做着朝九晚五的工作，你的目标是帮助人们感觉更好，这真的，你知道，不是很客观。这需要很长时间。它
goes with, you know, the ups and downs of life. And that was certainly a time I really felt like I needed this really visible, tangible, you know, progress on my knitting project, because you can just see that in a way that you can't see progress in therapy. So I think that is really what appeals to younger people, the idea of, I think they feel like they want to get away from screens and do something. Also, maybe like a bigger project, something that's a bit slower, takes a bit more concentration and time. But I think having this visible, tangible outcome is really important for lots of us. Yeah, it really is. And, yeah, I'm with you that once you stop getting that kind of external measurement,
伴随着生活的起伏。那确实是我觉得我非常需要这种非常可见、有形的编织项目进展的时候，因为你可以以一种在心理治疗中无法看到进展的方式看到它。所以我认为这确实是吸引年轻人的地方，那种他们觉得想要远离屏幕去做点什么的想法。此外，也许像一个更大的项目，一些更慢、需要更多专注和时间的东西。但我认为拥有这种可见、有形的成果对我们许多人来说真的很重要。是的，确实如此。而且，是的，我和你有同感，一旦你停止获得那种外部衡量标准，
it could be hard to maybe feel like you're progressing or to feel like you've got those dopamine hits of external validation. I love before we were speaking, I think you said that crochet and knitting is almost being talked about as a grandma hobby. Is that right? That's what the press love to write, Grandma Hobby, yeah. And I think one of the plus sides of social media is, I don't know about you, Paula, whether you were doing it when you were like, you know, 19-20.
可能很难感觉到自己在进步，或者很难感觉到你获得了那种外部验证带来的多巴胺冲击。我喜欢在我们交谈之前，我想你说过钩针编织和编织几乎被当作“奶奶爱好”来谈论。是这样吗？那是媒体喜欢写的，“奶奶爱好”，是的。而且我认为社交媒体的好处之一是，我不知道你呢，保拉，你在19-20岁的时候是否也在做这个。
But certainly I, when I was doing craft then, at that point for me, it was cross-stitch during my undergrad. And I did feel like I had to hide it from people because no one else was doing that. And I didn't know, you know, now having interviewed, I don't know how many people I've interviewed in my podcast, 60 people who were all, Many of them were like, oh yeah, I was the one person who brought their knitting to the pub when I was in my 20s. And now I know they're out there. And those people who are now in their 20s can connect, you know, on Instagram probably and know that someone else is doing it, even if nobody in their pub is doing it. But I think that there is still a bit of a stigma, I think, especially for younger people about this idea of it being a grandma hobby or for older people. But I don't necessarily think the press helps that by always referring to these things as grandma hobbies.
但我确实在做手工，那时对我来说，本科期间是十字绣。我确实觉得我不得不向别人隐瞒它，因为没有其他人这样做。我不知道，你知道，现在采访了，我不知道我在我的播客里采访了多少人，60个人，他们中的许多人说，“哦，是的，我是20多岁时唯一一个把编织带到酒吧的人。”现在我知道他们就在那里。那些现在20多岁的人可以在Instagram上联系，知道即使他们酒吧里没有人这样做，也有别人在做。但我认为仍然存在一点污名，特别是在年轻人中，关于它是一个“奶奶爱好”或适合老年人的想法。但我并不认为媒体总是把这些东西称为“奶奶爱好”会有所帮助。
Oh, thank you. When did you start knitting, Paula? How old were you? I was probably about seven. We had to knit at school. I grew up in South Africa and there was a tradition of lent knitting, so the 40 days before Easter. Everyone had to knit squares and then they would all be put together for blankets for charity. So my grandmother taught me to knit and we had to do it at school. So I feel, you know, always very grateful that I was given that skill as a young person
哦，谢谢。保拉，你什么时候开始编织的？你多大？我大概七岁左右。我们在学校必须编织。我在南非长大，有一种大斋期编织的传统，也就是复活节前的40天。每个人都必须编织方块，然后把它们拼在一起做成慈善毯子。所以我祖母教我编织，我们在学校也必须这样做。所以我感到，你知道，一直非常感激我年轻时就掌握了那项技能，
because it's something that I really, you know, turn to. Like when there's times when I feel, you know, really lost or overwhelmed and I'm like, I don't know, you know, what to do. I know I can go to knitting. And I really, it feels very panicky to me if I don't have a project that I can just pick up. Because, you know, that it has been a real anchor for me. So I'm very grateful that that was given that gift as a child to have learned. I feel like I can physically feel it in my body if I haven't knitted.
因为这是我真正求助的东西。就像当我感到非常迷茫或不知所措，不知道该怎么办的时候。我知道我可以去编织。如果我没有一个可以随手拿起的项目，我会感到非常恐慌。因为，你知道，它一直是我真正的锚。所以我非常感激作为一个孩子被赋予了那份学习的礼物。我觉得如果我不编织，我的身体能感觉到。
Like I've never been a smoker, but I remember like one of my grandmas used to smoke. she used to kind of get slightly like after her evening meal, like wanted a cigarette. And she seemed physically jittery. And I feel like I can, it's rare that I have a day where I won't knit a single stitch, but I feel like I can physiologically feel it if I haven't. Yeah. That's so interesting. It's almost like something around your hands. They need to move to kind of discharge the energy and process your day and create. Yeah, and I think it's probably been self-perpetuating, like, that it is my chosen coping strategy, and I guess on some level it's probably also a habit,
就像我从来没有抽过烟，但我记得我的一位祖母过去常抽烟。她晚饭后会有点像……想要一支烟。她看起来身体很焦躁。我觉得我可以，虽然我很少有一天不织一针，但如果我不织，我在生理上能感觉到。是的。这太有趣了。这几乎就像你的手周围有什么东西。它们需要移动来释放能量，处理你的一天并进行创造。是的，我认为这可能是自我强化的，它是我的首选应对策略，我想在某种程度上它可能也是一种习惯，
but certainly haven't really encountered any downsides in terms of as habits go. Yeah, and I think as both of you speak about it, I get this sense of it feeling really safe, and like you really get to have that deep exhale. And maybe it's something around that slight mindfulness kind of that allows you to disconnect from all the other stuff. That really, I can just see that it just really lights you up and it really helps you both to thrive. And I think why this is problematic is that so many people don't know
但作为习惯，我确实没有遇到任何负面影响。是的，当你们俩谈论它时，我感觉到一种非常安全的感觉，就像你真的可以进行那次深呼吸。也许这与那种轻微的正念有关，让你能够从所有其他事情中抽离出来。这真的，我能看出它真的点亮了你，它真的帮助你们俩茁壮成长。而且我认为这之所以成问题，是因为很多人不知道
what safety feels like or don't know what contentment and not having this swirling, mind and thoughts and pressures and and that's why i love showcasing when people are able to do that um who wants to talk to me about the safety that that comes from that yeah i was just going to say i guess that's one of the um the the kind of models that we use in our work around cft and thinking about you know how those um the three circles of emotion the threat drive and susy soothing system work and how knitting really offers us a way of, as you say, of accessing safety.
安全感是什么感觉，或者不知道满足感是什么感觉，没有这种纷乱的心思、想法和压力。这就是为什么我喜欢展示人们能够做到这一点的时候。嗯，谁想和我谈谈由此带来的安全感？是的，我正想说，我想那是我们在工作中围绕CFT（慈悲聚焦疗法）使用的一种模型，思考那三个情绪圆环——威胁、驱动和舒缓系统——是如何运作的，以及编织如何真正为我们提供一种进入安全感的方式。
You know, knitting can, you know, it can be frustrating when you're, when you're starting to learn. So, you know, that is a reality too, that you've got to kind of get over that, that hump. But that also offers opportunities for, you know, practicing and learning some of these skills around noticing your body, you know, being. aware of what it feels like these kind of sensations, how it feels like to get into a soothing rhythm. And, you know, that noticing of, you know, you can't really rush knitting or you're going to make mistakes. So, you know, you need to be able to slow down. And we often talk about
你知道，当你开始学习时，编织可能会令人沮丧。所以，这也是一个现实，你必须克服那个障碍。但这也提供了练习和学习一些关于注意身体、意识到这种感觉是什么、进入舒缓节奏的感觉的技能的机会。而且，你知道，那种注意到你不能真正匆忙编织，否则你会犯错。所以，你需要能够慢下来。我们经常谈论
how knitting offers a really low stakes way of relating to all sorts of things that we come up in our daily life like making mistakes like frustration tolerance like you know having to wait you know perfectionism all of those things will show up in your knitting but it offers a way to play with that and to relate differently to those things which then are able to kind of generalize to our life more broadly as well as just being in the moment helpful and at the end of of the day creating something beautiful that might be something useful or that you give away or that you keep. And often knitters will talk about, well, knitters differ actually. You know, for some knitters, it's much more about the process and they're like really not attached to what they make.
编织如何提供一种非常低风险的方式来处理我们在日常生活中遇到的各种事情，比如犯错、挫折容忍度、等待、完美主义，所有这些事情都会在你的编织中表现出来。但它提供了一种方式来玩转这些事情，并以不同的方式与它们建立联系，这随后能够推广到我们更广泛的生活中，而不仅仅是当下的帮助。在一天结束时，创造出一些美丽的东西，可能是实用的，或者你送给别人，或者你自己留着。编织者经常会谈论，嗯，其实编织者各不相同。你知道，对于一些编织者来说，这更多是关于过程，他们并不执着于他们制作的东西。
For other people, the finished outcome is really important. For me, the process is absolutely paramount, But the objects are very meaningful. And, you know, I have things that, you know, were made, are not good making, but mean a lot to me because they were part of a, either a very difficult part of my life or, you know, something that meant a lot. So there's really symbolic meaning and value in the projects. So that kind of relationship to learning more about ourselves and being able to develop self compassion through this kind of practice, I think is really valuable.
对于其他人来说，最终的成果非常重要。对我来说，过程绝对是至关重要的，但这些物品非常有意义。而且，你知道，我有一些东西，不是很好的作品，但对我意义重大，因为它们是我生活中非常困难的一部分，或者意味着很多。所以这些项目具有真正的象征意义和价值。因此，那种通过这种实践了解更多关于我们自己并能够培养自我同情心的关系，我认为非常有价值。
And people talk about that, about knitting being a safe place for them a way to access safety. And often it's like a really tangible, it's like something to hold onto. You know, people will talk about and this has been true for me, you know, those kind of worst moments of your life where you're waiting for something or, you know, something terrible and you're helpless, but actually being able to hold on to something and just literally, you know, have keeping your hands busy while you're doing something that is familiar and soothing can, you know, get you through. That was something I've been supervising a thesis based on the interviews from my podcast with people with experience of psychological distress and how they've used knitting as a tool to manage that.
人们谈论编织是他们的安全之地，一种获得安全感的方式。它通常是一种非常具体的东西，就像可以抓住的东西。你知道，人们会谈论——这对我来说也是真的——那些你生命中最糟糕的时刻，你在等待某事，或者发生了可怕的事情，你感到无助，但实际上能够抓住某物，仅仅是字面上地，让你的手忙碌起来，同时做一些熟悉和舒缓的事情，可以让你度过难关。我一直在指导一篇论文，基于我播客中对有心理困扰经历的人的采访，以及他们如何利用编织作为管理工具。
And one of the themes that has come out of that kind of thesis was about this idea of it's something I can always do, no matter how dark things are or often, for example, with grief, because it's not a problem you can solve. But the idea of being able to do something and the kind of just having this action that you feel like it's always there, I think there's something very important in not feeling out. of options of something you can do in really difficult time.
从那篇论文中得出的主题之一是关于“无论事情多么黑暗，我总能做这件事”的想法。或者通常，例如在悲伤中，因为这不是一个你能解决的问题。但能够做某事，以及那种感觉它总是在那里的行动，我认为在感到没有选择、在非常困难的时期能做点什么方面，是非常重要的。
So yeah. Yeah, it really is. And obviously with the cost of living crisis at the moment, how can we make it more accessible for more people? Because I think the last time I saw the price of a ball of wool when I was in a shop, I was a little bit shocked. How is the cost of living crisis impacting on crochet and wool at the moment? Well, I think it's, I mean, it depends where you go.
所以是的。是的，确实如此。显然，在目前的生活成本危机下，我们如何让更多人更容易接触到它？因为我想上次我在店里看到一团毛线的价格时，我有点震惊。生活成本危机目前对钩针编织和毛线有什么影响？嗯，我认为，我的意思是，这取决于你去哪里。
I mean, we can be extremely expensive, but you can also get it in charity shops for, you know, less than two pounds a bore. You know, you, they often, charity shops are often full of needles. You know, any knitter will have hundreds of needles they're not using. So you will be able to borrow. It's, you know, you don't need to spend a lot of money. And I think that's one of the things that's really valuable to think of something that has loads of benefits. You know, some of the studies that we've looked at, you know, have, for example, you know, a study looking at knitting in an eating disorder unit, in drug and alcohol treatment.
我的意思是，我们可以非常昂贵，但你也可以在慈善商店以不到两英镑一团的价格买到。你知道，慈善商店里通常装满了针。任何编织者都会有数百根他们不用的针。所以你能够借到。它，你知道，你不需要花很多钱。我认为这是思考具有很多好处的事情时非常有价值的一点。你知道，我们看过的研究，例如，一项关于饮食失调病房、药物和酒精治疗中编织的研究。
You know, one of the things that they talk about is how, but the amazing potential that knitting has as an intervention, given that it is so cheap, you know, doesn't have a dangerous side effect profile and is so broadly kind of accessible and acceptable to people. You know, cost should not be a barrier. You can definitely spend hundreds of pounds, but you can also spend two pounds and, you know, have something lovely. Okay, that's good to know. Maybe I was in a S1 p boutique or something at the target.
你知道，他们谈论的一件事是，编织作为一种干预手段的惊人潜力，因为它非常便宜，没有危险的副作用，而且对人们来说非常广泛地可接受。你知道，成本不应该成为障碍。你绝对可以花几百英镑，但你也可以花两英镑，拥有一件可爱的作品。好的，很高兴知道。也许我当时是在精品店之类的。
Charity shops for sure. Okay. You know, new yarn. Beautiful, yeah. Excellent advice. Thank you. So it sounds like they're starting to become an evidence-based. So even you're creating some evidence-based, Maria, with thesis, you're supervising, which I love.
慈善商店肯定有。好的。新的纱线。美丽的，是的。极好的建议。谢谢。所以听起来它们开始变得有循证依据了。所以你甚至在创造一些循证依据，玛丽亚，通过你指导的论文，我喜欢这一点。
And then there's other research that's starting to come through that's really cementing how good for people's well-being, kind of wool-based activities are. And I guess we'd want to see more of that. Yeah, it's interesting. Betts and Corkill, who was a physiotherapist, became the authority in this area of research. She was involved with quite a few of the bigger kind of survey-based research studies in the field of knitting and mental health. And she was talking to me on my podcast about the idea of struggling to get funding.
然后还有其他研究开始出现，真正巩固了基于毛线的活动对人们的幸福感有多好。我想我们希望看到更多这样的研究。是的，这很有趣。贝茨和科基尔（Betts and Corkill）是一位物理治疗师，成为了该研究领域的权威。她参与了编织和心理健康领域不少较大的调查类研究。她在我的播客上谈到了难以获得资金的想法。
And I think it's a show, so as part of, as Paula said earlier, as part of the Y I knit podcast, we've got this journal club. series where we look and do a deep dive into the papers in the area. And it's a real shame because some of the ones we've discussed recently are they're not actually that recent. And that, you know, there's a really, I think it was like 2008, 2007 and, you know, really shows amazing like a reduction in anxious preoccupation in people with anorexia and an inpatient service. And you think actually probably somewhere like that, there aren't a whole host of interventions. People might be on bed rest or might have to be seated. They're not going to be allowed to do a lot of movement or
我认为这是一个展示，正如保拉早些时候所说，作为“我为什么编织”（Why I Knit）播客的一部分，我们有这个期刊俱乐部系列，我们深入研究该领域的论文。这真的很遗憾，因为我们最近讨论的一些论文其实并不那么新。而且，你知道，真的，我想是2008年、2007年左右，真的显示出住院服务中厌食症患者焦虑担忧的惊人减少。你会想，实际上像那样的地方，并没有大量的干预措施。人们可能需要卧床休息或必须坐着。他们不会被允许进行大量的运动或
any sports or exercise. And to have something that is people report is reducing their kind of anxious thoughts. That's really powerful. But actually there hasn't been then further kind of follow-up studies. And Betts and Cork Hill spoke about really struggling if she mentioned the K word. She couldn't get funding. But if she talked about it as a bilateral psychosocial intervention, all of a sudden people, you know, there is pricked up and they were potentially interested in this new research area. So I think there has potentially been a bit of stigma against it being missing, but certainly that was her perception as someone who was trying to kind of, you know, fight for research
任何体育锻炼。而拥有一些人们报告说能减少他们焦虑想法的东西，那真的很强大。但实际上并没有后续的追踪研究。贝茨和科基尔谈到，如果她提到“K”（Knitting，编织）这个词，她就无法获得资金。但如果她将其称为“双侧心理社会干预”，突然间人们就竖起耳朵，对这个新的研究领域产生了潜在的兴趣。所以我认为，对于编织可能存在一点污名，但这确实是她作为一个试图争取研究资金的人的看法。
funding. I think it's really hard to get all research funded, but yeah, but certainly there are some studies out there and we're trying to contribute to that. Something around knitting not being quite sexy enough to hold its own. I was just going to say, I think that's one of the tricky things about it having this label of being a grandma hobby, because it's kind of relegated to this sort of domestic, feminine space. And I think, you know, it's only been in very recent history of knitting that that's been the case. You know, it always used to be a very, you know, men used to do it and a very kind of highly appreciated kind of
我认为获得所有研究资金都很难，但确实有一些研究存在，我们正在努力为此做出贡献。关于编织不够“性感”而无法独立存在。我正想说，我认为这是它被贴上“奶奶爱好”标签的棘手之处之一，因为它被降级到了这种家庭的、女性的空间。而且我认为，你知道，编织只是在非常近的历史中才变成这样。你知道，它过去一直是非常，你知道，男人过去也做，而且是一种非常受赞赏的艺术行会，直到编织机出现。然后，它开始更多地成为有闲暇时间的女士们会做的事情。我认为这降低了它的价值。它被视为一种“奶奶爱好”，而实际上它是一种强大的心理社会艺术实践。所以我认为这是我们动机的一部分，真正展示它，并把它从那种空间中带出来。谢谢，保拉。
of guilds, you know, artistic guild until knitting machines came along. And, you know, then it started to be more of something that ladies with spare time would be doing. And that has kind of, I think, downgraded the, you know, the value of it. And it's seen as a grandma hobby when actually it is, you know, a powerful psychosocial, you know, art practice. And so that I think is part of our motivation is to really, you know, showcase it and bring it out of that kind of space. Thank you, Paula.
（注：原文索引33与34内容重叠，此处按原文顺序翻译）
We're recording this at a point where I've broken my hand. So I've been thinking a lot about hand mobility and hand health and how annoying it is to be. incapacitated. Is there much evidence that knitting and crochet is protective of hand health and hand mobility? I don't know so much about, I guess, I think it depends, there's a quite a diverse field of issues with hands. I think there's been some study maybe about neuropathy or maybe pain after chemotherapy and knitting and that reducing. Certainly there are, you know, I've interviewed a physiotherapist who specialises in, she works more with that cross.
我们录制这段节目时，我的手骨折了。所以我一直在思考手部灵活性和手部健康，以及丧失能力是多么令人恼火。有没有很多证据表明编织和钩针编织对保护手部健康和灵活性有作用？我不太了解，我想这取决于，我认为手部问题领域非常多样。我想可能有一些关于神经病变或化疗后疼痛的研究，编织能减轻这些。当然，你知道，我采访过一位物理治疗师，她专门研究与手工相关的疼痛，但也见过各种手部问题的人，他们是热爱编织或手工并希望恢复的人。作为一名编织者，她也理解这一点。所以我不太了解。我确实收到人们的消息，你知道，显然主持一个关于编织及其好处的播客，我收到很多人的消息说，你知道，它帮助他们克服了各种困难。但我不知道研究是什么。
craft-related pain, but also sees people who've got various hand issues who are, you know, people who love to knit or craft and want to get back to doing that. And she understands that as somebody who knits as well. So I don't know so much. I do get people, you know, obviously hosting a podcast about knitting and its benefits. I get lots of messages from people who say, you know, it's helped with various difficulties they've been struggling with. but I don't know what the research is.
我想我们更多地关注心理健康方面。那是你的狗吗，米娅。那不是你的狗吗？我听到了狗叫声。其他人也听到了吗？是的，好的。完美。好的。
I guess we focus more on the kind of mental health side of things. That's your dog, Mia. Is that not your dog? I heard a dog. Did everyone else hear a dog? Yeah, okay. Perfect. All right.
所以你们聚在一起，开始了“创造性恢复”（Creative Restoration）。保拉，你能告诉我们一点关于“创造性恢复”的事吗？是的，所以我们有一个小生意，我们一起创建在线课程、网络研讨会，直播和点播，我们教授我们关于编织心理健康益处的方法。所以我们涵盖了广泛的主题。我们有专注于解读关于编织心理健康益处研究的网络研讨会。所以看看科学，看看，
So you guys have kind of got together and you've started creative restoration. Paula, could you tell us a bit about creative restoration? Yeah, so we, we, have a kind of little business together where we are creating online courses, webinars, live and on demand, where we teach our kind of approach to the mental health benefits of knitting. So we cover kind of wide range of topics. We've got webinars that are focused on unpacking the research around the mental health benefits of knitting. So looking at the science, looking at,
我们有一个米娅和她女儿们一起精心绘制的模型，说明了这些东西在理论上是如何交织在一起的。所以我们有那个关于编织和心理健康的内容。然后我们有关于编织和倦怠（burnout）的更具体的课程。所以我的临床工作是与卫生专业人员和倦怠打交道。所以思考编织在预防和恢复倦怠中可以发挥的作用，不仅对卫生专业人员，而且对任何人，你知道，父母，我们所有面临超负荷和不知所措风险的人。我们还有一个关于注意力和专注力的网络研讨会，以及编织能为我们提供什么好处。
we've got a kind of model that Mia has beautifully drawn together with her daughters that illustrates how these things are woven together in theory. And so we've got that looking at kind of knitting and mental health. And then we have more specific offers around knitting and burnout. So my kind of clinical work is around working with health professionals and burnout. So thinking about the role that knitting can play in burnout prevention and recovery, not just for health professionals, but for anyone who, you know, parents, all of us who are at risk of overloads and overwhelm. And we've also got a webinar around attention and focus and the impact of what benefits
我们有一个即将到来的关于悲伤计划，关于编织和悲伤的研讨会。然后我们有一个，我们的标志性在线课程叫做“一针一线自我关怀”（Self-Care One Stitch at a Time），这是一个基于接纳承诺疗法（ACT）的课程。所以它有点像使用编织作为学习基于ACT的自我关怀技能的一种方式，但也使用ACT来帮助人们对他们编织什么和如何编织做出有意的选择，以支持他们的自我关怀和幸福感。所以那是一个在线音频课程，是的，它在我们的网站上都可以访问。
knitting can offer for us there. We've got one, an upcoming one about grief plans, about knitting and grief. And then we have a, our signature online course is called Self-Care One Stitch at a Time, which is an acceptance and commitment therapy based course. So it's kind of using knitting as a way of learning acts-based skills for self-care, but also using Act to help people make intentional choices about what and how they knit to support their self-care and well-being. So that's a kind of online audio course that, yeah, and it's all kind of accessible on our website.
谢谢，保拉。那么当我们谈论注意力时，在结束之前，你知道，人们普遍说Netflix有一些节目是“第二屏幕友好”的，这样人们可以多任务处理，这样他们可以，广义上说，在观看的同时仍然消费他们的垂直内容。编织与此不同吗？因为显然我们试图思考也许这不是最好的习惯，但看起来编织并不完全属于那个“第二屏幕”类别。是的，我想我会说，而且我想米娅你可能会同意，你知道，在电视前编织绝对是——如果我不编织，我会100%睡着。
Thank you, Paula. Whilst we're talking about attention then, just before we finish, you know, It's widely said that Netflix, you know, have some programming that they do, that's second-screen friendly so that people can multitask so they can, you know, be watching, broadly speaking, and then still consuming their vertical content. Is knitting different than that? Because obviously we're trying to think maybe that's not the best habits to be developing, but it seems like knitting doesn't quite fall into that second screen category. Yeah, I guess I would say, and I think that Mia, you'd probably agree that, you know, knitting in front of TV is definitely like if I don't knit, I will fall asleep like 100%.
所以对我来说，编织支持我看电视。它有助于集中注意力。我想，你知道，我发现静坐很难，但如果我有忙碌的事情，你知道，让我的手忙碌起来，它有助于我做到这一点。在线培训之类的也是一样。所以，我想它确实有帮助的是，你知道，我认为我们可以把编织看作是占据了忙碌的工作记忆，这样我们大脑的其余部分就能够安定下来，并对当下发生的事情更加专注。而且我认为这是一种更丰富的体验，特别是如果你与其他人分享这一点的话。你知道，这比你玩手机更少是一种社交阻碍。
So for me, the knitting supports my TV watching. It helps to concentrate. I think, you know, I find it quite hard just to sit still. but if I have something busy, you know, keeping my hands busy, it helps me to do that. It's the same of kind of online training or something. So, and I guess what it does help, though, is, you know, I think we can think of of knitting a bit like occupying that busy working memory so that the rest of our brain is able to settle and be more present with what's there. And then I think that's a richer experience, especially if you're sharing that with someone else. You know, it's less of a kind of social block
而且这实际上也相当令人疲惫，我想。你知道，然后你的思想真的在，你知道，那种分散的注意力可能感觉有点像垃圾食品类型的体验。就像你一直很忙，但事后有点空虚。而我认为对我以及我们交谈过的许多人来说，编织可以支持那种更丰富的注意力集中。
than you being on your phone. And which is also quite exhausting actually, I think. You know, then your mind is really in, you know, that divided attention can feel, I suppose, a bit like a junk food type experience. Like you've been really busy, but it's a bit empty afterwards. Whereas I think for me and for lots of people, you know, who we've spoken to, knitting can support that richer attentional focus.
而且你还有一些东西，你知道，你在做的时候正在朝着某个目标取得进展。我认为这也是一种不同的输入渠道，因为我想我的孩子们有时告诉我他们可以同时看书和听有声读物。我不认为那是真的。或者你知道，甚至像同时阅读Instagram标题和听播客，我是在切换注意力，而编织更像是开车和交谈，因为它是肌肉记忆过程，没有语言，它在我的手中，我可以选择。这是编织的另一个伟大之处，你可以选择简单和困难的程度，就像
And also you've got something, you know, you're making progress towards something while you're at it. I think it's also a different channel of input because I think my children sometimes tell me they can read a book and listen to an audio book at the same time. And I don't think that's true. or you know like even so i think reading something like reading an instagram caption at the same time as listening to a podcast i'm switching attention right whereas knitting is more like driving a car and having a conversation because it's a motem it's a muscle memory process it's not there's no verbal it's in my hands and i can choose that's the other one of the great things about knitting is you can just choose the gradations of easy and difficult like
在我的角落里，我有复杂的东西，所以我必须读图表，我也有简单的东西，我可以在我们进行这次谈话时做，你不会知道，因为我根本没有看我的手。我只是在织随机的圆圈。我认为这是伟大的地方，我可以根据我大脑在那一天需要什么来选择。我想这就是我们的全部，通过自我关怀的视角来看待编织，提倡，那种你用来对编织项目做出选择的视角，它是为了服务你，而不是为了完成一件惊人的开衫之类的东西。太棒了。所以从最低限度来看，这本质上可以就像一个指尖玩具，就像一个
in my corner I've got complicated things, so I have to read a chart, and I've got easy things where I could be doing it while we're having this conversation, and you wouldn't know, because I'm not looking at my hands at all. I'm just knitting random circles. And I think that's the great thing that I can pick up on any one day what my brain needs. And I guess that's our whole thing is looking at knitting through the lens of self-care, like advocating, kind of that's the lens through which you make choices about your knitting project, that it's there to serve you rather than to get to the end of completing an amazing cardigan or whatever. Great. So at its lowest end, this essentially could just be like a fidget toy, like a
挤压的东西，帮助调节你并让你保持专注。我喜欢这一点。好的，谢谢。我知道你们俩都有播客。米娅，告诉我们一点关于你的播客。所以我的播客叫做“我为什么编织”（Why I Knit）。所以在主系列中，我每一集都会采访一位不同的编织者，关于他们为什么编织以及编织如何有益于他们的心理健康。所以他们中有些是针织品设计师。有些是，你知道，是的，谈论心理健康和编织的人，或者现在与我联系并谈论强大经历的人。他们觉得编织对他们的心理健康有益。然后在这之间，保拉和我创建了一些奖励剧集。所以其中一些是期刊俱乐部，我们深入
squeezy thing to help to help regulate you and keep you focused. I love that. Okay, thank you. I know both of you have got podcasts. Mia, tell us a little bit about your podcast. So my podcast is called Why I Knit. So in the main series, I interview each episode a different knitter about why they knit and how knitting benefits their mental health. So some of them are knitware designers. Some of them are you know, yeah, people who've, many people who've kind of talked about mental health and knitting, or people have now got in touch with me and talked about kind of powerful experiences. They've felt that knitting has kind of been beneficial to their mental health. And then in between those, Paula and I create kind of bonus episodes. So some of those are the journal club where we take a deep
研究期刊文章，它们实际上非常受欢迎。我们有很多卫生和教育专业人员，他们有兴趣在工作中利用编织来造福他人。所以，我们做了一些读书俱乐部剧集和一些奖励反思剧集，我们收集主题。例如，我们很快会发布一集关于低落情绪的，我们回顾并听了几集人们谈论抑郁和低落情绪的剧集，并提供了我们的反思。所以这就是我的播客。谢谢，保拉。告诉我们你的播客。是的，所以我的播客叫做“当工作受伤时”（When Work Hurt）。
dive into journal articles and they're actually very popular. We've got quite a lot of kind of health and education professionals who are kind of interested in using knitting to benefit others as part of their work. So, and we've done some book club episodes and some kind of bonus reflective episodes where we kind of collect themes. So for example, we've got one coming out soon about low mood where we've gone back and listened to a few episodes where people have talked about depression and low mood and kind of offered our reflections on that. So that's my podcast. Thank you, Paula. Tell us about your podcast. Yes, so my podcast is called When Work Hurt.
它专门研究作为卫生专业人员的问题，特别是目前在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）中的问题。所以它涵盖了广泛的问题。最近我们做了一些关于患有ADHD并成为卫生专业人员、在投诉中幸存的系列，你知道，当你收到执业能力投诉时那有多困难，以及在这些情况下非常有帮助的经历和建议。今年秋天，我将与那些关于应对书籍的作者合作，这些书籍是协会的
And it's specifically looking at the kind of issues around being a health professional, specifically in the NHS at the moment. And so it covers a wide range of issues. And recently we've done some series around kind of having ADHD and being a health professional, surviving complaints, you know, what, that you know how difficult that is when you receive a fitness to practice complaint and and you know the experiences and advice that could be really helpful in those circumstances and coming up this autumn I'm doing a series with the authors of the coping with books that the Association of
它专门关注目前作为一名医疗专业人员，特别是在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）中工作所面临的各类问题。它涵盖了广泛的议题。最近，我们制作了一些系列节目，探讨了患有ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍）的医疗专业人员的生存现状，以及如何应对投诉。你知道，当你收到关于执业能力的投诉时，那有多么困难。我们分享了在这些情况下非常有帮助的经验和建议。今年秋天，我将与《应对》（Coping with）系列丛书的作者们合作推出一个新系列，该书由协会出版。
Clinical Psychology has published so that is looking at psychologists clinical psychologists who've written books about experiences that they've been through like breast cancer, menopause, or other life stage issues like, you know, young parenting and children. And the kind of personal, professional boundaries and sort of relationships. They're like, how does that impact you being a psychologist? And how does being a psychologist impact those experiences? So that's what's coming up. Perfect. Thank you. And where can people learn more about Creative Restoration? Is your website the best place to go?
《临床心理学》已经出版了，它关注的是那些撰写过自身经历书籍的临床心理学家，比如乳腺癌、更年期或其他人生阶段的问题，像年轻父母育儿等。还有关于个人与职业界限以及人际关系的问题。比如，这如何影响你作为心理学家的身份？而作为心理学家又如何影响这些经历？这就是即将推出的内容。太棒了。谢谢。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于“创造性修复”的信息？网站是最好的渠道吗？
Yeah. So our website is CreativeRestoration.org. So you can find us there. We're both on Instagram. Mia's definitely better on Instagram than I am. So yeah, we can find us there as well. Great. What are your Instagram handles and I'll make sure that they're on screen and in the show notes? So mine is at Dr. Paula Redmond. And mine is knitting is therapeutic. Perfect. Thank you so much for your time and so sharing a little bit of your knitting world with us. It's so gratefully received.
是的。我们的网站是CreativeRestoration.org。你可以在那里找到我们。我们都在Instagram上。Mia在Instagram上肯定比我活跃。所以，是的，你也可以在那里找到我们。太好了。你们的Instagram账号是什么？我会确保它们显示在屏幕上并写在节目说明里。我的账号是@Dr.PaulaRedmond。我的账号是@knittingistherapeutic。非常感谢你们抽出时间，并与我们分享你们的编织世界。我们非常感激。
Well, thank you for having us. Thank you. Thanks so much for watching. Are you crafty? Are you knitting? Are you crocheting? Or are you maybe now, frankly, after this compelling display, considering having a go. I would love to know whether you are taking up any of the grandparent style hobbies or whether it might feel appealing to you to do so.
谢谢你们邀请我们。谢谢。非常感谢大家的观看。你心灵手巧吗？你会编织吗？你会钩针编织吗？或者，坦白说，在看了这次精彩的展示后，你是否正在考虑尝试一下？我很想知道你是否正在尝试任何“祖辈风格”的爱好，或者这样做是否对你有吸引力。
As I said in the episode, I have broken my hand at the moment. And when I was in the hospital, I purposely took with me some books and things like that so that I wouldn't be beholden to needing a phone charger. And when I looked around the waiting room, I was the only person not on my phone and using what I now know of as an analogue hobby of reading. And I shared this little anecdote with Dr. Mia as we were preparing to record and she said that when she'd been to the hospital She had her knitting and a knitting bag with her because she was expecting a long stay and actually looking around at how fractures and agitated some of the other people were She is considering next time she goes taking some spare knitting noodles and spare yarn and teaching people to knit I would love to know what your thoughts are on this if you were in a hospital or GP practice waiting room somewhere where you're going to be anticipating having a bit of a weight and someone offered you a free little
正如我在节目中所说，我目前手骨折了。当我在医院时，我特意带了一些书之类的东西，这样我就不必依赖手机充电器了。当我环顾候诊室时，我是唯一一个没有看手机，而是使用我现在所知的“模拟爱好”——阅读的人。我在准备录制时与Mia博士分享了这个小轶事，她说当她去医院时，她随身带着编织品和编织袋，因为她预计会待很长时间。实际上，看着周围其他人是多么焦躁不安，她正在考虑下次去的时候带上一些多余的编织针和毛线，教人们编织。我很想知道你们对此有何看法，如果你在医院或全科医生诊所的候诊室里，预计要等一会儿，有人为你提供一个免费的小型
knitting lesson workshop what would you say if you're watching on youtube let me know in the comments if you're listening on mp3 let me know on socials or on spotify you can drop a comment for specific episodes too have you yet discovered inner work they are my solo deep dive behind the scenes kind of in-depth look at some of the themes cropping up from the psychology actually episodes. They are now totally free, but if you do like getting early access to inner work and to psychology, actually, you can still subscribe. The inner work episodes are available from 8pm UK time, wherever you get your podcasts and on YouTube. And before we go, if you've enjoyed this episode, I think you'll really like the one I did previously with Dr. Mia Hobbs, because
编织课程工作坊，你会怎么说？如果你是在YouTube上观看，请在评论区告诉我；如果你是在听音频，请在社交媒体上或Spotify上告诉我，你也可以在特定剧集下发表评论。你发现“内在工作”了吗？这是我个人的深度剖析，幕后花絮，深入探讨了从《心理学，实际上》剧集中出现的一些主题。它们现在完全免费，但如果你喜欢提前收听“内在工作”和《心理学，实际上》，你仍然可以订阅。“内在工作”剧集于英国时间晚上8点发布，你可以在任何获取播客的地方以及YouTube上收听。在结束之前，如果你喜欢这一集，我想你也会非常喜欢我之前与Mia Hobbs博士录制的那一集，因为
this was her second time on the podcast. There's details on the screen or in show notes. Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational each and every person's journey was. And using these stories
这是她第二次参加播客。屏幕上或节目说明中有详细信息。嗨，我叫Emily。我是一名在南安普顿学习临床心理学的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，以帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我买了它。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程非常有启发性，这让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多思考。它还有助于客观地看待事物，并提醒我，如果今年没能考上博士，也没关系。然而，这本书最意想不到的乐趣在于，每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心。利用这些故事
as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
作为我每天早上的动力真是一种享受。我几乎不舍得读完它。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。